it's good to be here with everybody
today and I think our studio audience
and our YouTube audience for coming I
have been blessed by what Mikey just
shared with us there was things that he
presented that I have never you know
looked into we live in a world where we
are literally putting Christian on
everything I just like to do yoga cuz
it's all about stretching it relieves me
of stress and things like this but when
I saw that there's a holy yoga now
yoga's not only taking the world by
storm but it's coming into our churches
by storm when I see holy yoga and
knowing the meaning of yoga and what it
means in a religious sense
that's like saying holy voodoo this lady
that we just watched you know Brooke we
need to pray for her
obviously she has been blinded to the
powers that are actually there so we
don't need to attack people or belittle
them but we need to pray for him and
while we're doing that we still have to
keep exposing darkness with light what
we want to look at now is is the roots
what are the roots of this practice that
so many Christians now unknowingly are
accepting find out on this episode of
LED live
[Music]
exposing darkness just a quick note if
you want more information there's the
documentary called yoga uncoiled that's
available powerful DVD that was done
from a lady that passed away a few years
ago her name is Carol matrisciana very
very powerful documentary and then we
also have got a series here at little
light studios called the dragon revealed
down under and that Australian series we
go into quite a bit on yoga and we've
got some other ones available on YouTube
for free what we're going to look at is
the roots of that tree we're looking at
a time magazine here where they are
showing a lady in the yoga pose one of
the yoga poses and the title is the
science of yoga millions of Americans
are discovering this ancient exercise
but here's the skinny on why it makes
you feel so good people will tell me
that they'll say yeah but I feel great
when I get finished and I'm like well
when I was in the martial arts after
I've been doing it for about eight or
ten years I could do a kata or a form
like a Shaolin form and I would do that
one form and I would be like man I am
like fired up I mean you felt like you
could fight a grizzly bear
what's because when I was doing those
forms I was invoking unknowingly
spiritual powers to strengthen me to
energize me and when people would do
yoga they'd do the same thing the devil
says if it makes you feel good do it
then the Bible talked about a guy who
was possessed and he was able to break
chains I mean this is biblical it's real
it's not yes what you're saying is a
real thing yes sir the art of yoga we're
gonna watch a DVD actually a couple of
film clips here we're gonna watch a
couple of film clips to sort of
introduce this idea and the questions
that are going through a lot of
Americans and Western minds right now
Yoga has spread around our planet in the
last 50 years in an unprecedented way
there really is no government office in
India called spread yoga around the
world and there's no billions of dollars
that have been spent on getting it out
to the world instead a few people left
India a few usually rather elderly men
and women came taught it but there was a
demand so Yoga is sweeping the world
because it's fulfilling a need it isn't
against anything
it isn't sectarian it doesn't promote a
particular sectarian religious view it's
actually the ancient art of being
peaceful and happy with oneself being
able to go inside find peace of mind not
having to buy it from somewhere get it
from something not needing a drug or a
pill or an upper or a downer funnily
enough yoga teaches us and we don't know
how to breathe and we don't understand
that calm balanced poised breathing
immediately is connected to the mind and
sends the signal to the mind relax
everything is fine don't worry and you
see we could fall over this way or fall
over this way or we could find the
balance point how to live in harmony
with your body in your body and your
body in nature and find the peace that
you need to make it through each day as
your best self I found that very hard to
believe because ancient civilizations
were very religious you know correct me
if I'm wrong but there was no such thing
as atheists back then if you would go to
any civilization they would ask you even
in the Bible there's accounts you know
who is your God or what is this God that
you worship so just to say that they
were these exercises done just to
increase your breathing or to clear mind
whatever the case I just find a hard
smooth that there was no spiritual
connection back then even in ancient
times good point you know when I look at
what's happening especially over the
last ten years
Satan is seeking to erase the lines you
know back at the Tower of Babel God
divided the nation's for a purpose
because he saw that when man
without Christ without Christ dwelling
within his heart mankind was just
opposed to God so God said I don't want
to destroy people so I'm gonna separate
them I'm gonna divide them so that we
can keep them from from being under the
rulership and the influence of Satan but
now Satan is working to erase those
boundaries to erase those lines it
doesn't mean that we need to think we're
better than another person but at the
same time it was never God's purpose for
paganism and the true worship of Yahweh
or Jehovah to be blended there's another
clip I want you to see he talked about
how yoga is is flooding especially the
West you know Europe and England and the
United States this was an Eastern
concept Yoga has always been a religious
practice but now it's being brought into
our country as if it's just exercise
look at what just happened recently neon
lights bustling commuters trying to find
some inner peace at the crossroads of
the world is certainly a case of mind
over matter The Times Square Yoga is
held every year on June the 31st this is
its 16th year and it's still drawing
first-timers like me away from my job
and give me a nice break free classes
stretch the full 5 blocks of Times
Square at about 2,000 people taking part
in each session organizer and long-term
yogi Douglas Stewart has seen it grow
the first year with just three people
including himself that took part is it
possible to find that inner stillness
with all the distraction
in a normal life you know this is one of
the metaphor for all of that distraction
and from above it sounds and seems like
that piece might just be possible never
before has an hour in Times Square been
so relaxing something that's
unexplainable I feel like everybody
should just experience I felt calm I
felt peace
I felt stillness which is you know weird
in the midst of all of this you know all
this commotion and the sirens and
everything but it was like I was at the
beach well whether you're an expert or
like me a complete beginner this is
really about coming together and giving
it a go Nick Harper CT TN New York you
know that's amazing this is about coming
together becoming one and we're gonna
see as we do this there's a reason why
satan is striving to these ends
according to current demographics there
are more than 650 million practitioners
of martial arts Tai Chi and yoga
worldwide a recent study from the USA
Today magazine reveals that yoga has
grown to be a twenty seven billion
dollar industry Wow twenty seven billion
dollars billion with a B you know it's
funny though cuz when I first began
training in these arts you know you had
to you had to find somewhere to order
yoga like a magazine or something you
couldn't just go down to Walmart and
think of videos or a yoga mat and and
the clothing industry loves it because
everybody that does yoga has got to look
like a superhero and you think wait a
minute why are they all wearing skin
tight pants I mean what's up with that
the the people in India don't do that
most of the people in India are male
yoga is not traditionally known as a
female practice there are some that do
but most of them are male and when you
see the images of just like lots of
people doing yoga like what we just saw
in New York I mean it's predominantly
female the holy yoga it's predominantly
female yeah and I want to say like that
totally looked like I was looking at a
worse
ceremony mats people bowing and humming
and about peace and you know let's say
it's not religious but that's exactly
what any temple looks like they're
sitting on a mat they're bowing they're
humming and all this stuff and and for
inium for me I think can you not well I
think how to put this you ask why do you
have to wear skintight clothes well so
we can stretch what can't you do that in
a pair of baggy flannel you know pajama
bottoms or a pair of sweatpants you know
why do you have so it's like the Super
Heroes you know why do they have
spray-painted because you can see every
curve of the body
most of the men that are practicing that
you'll see that are teachers there they
have very little on they're trying to
show their body an Eden man when they
fell and sinned they ran to hide because
they were unclosed now we're proud of it
it would take a real skill to clear your
mind and to be focused when all of that
is around you yeah it's not it's not a
skill you practice it and then something
else comes in and takes the driver's
seat and you sit in the passenger's seat
and just watch and that's what they want
that's what the purpose is this is from
that documentary yoga uncoiled and they
go in and they do some interviews with
actual Hindu gurus in India but then
they also interview former Indian by
religion who have now become Christian
and they listen to what they say about
this practice author Jean Lim lecturer
and authority on the supernatural lives
in Malaysia Yoga is actually a form of
special exercise and those who practice
yoga they will be filled you know with
the register of yoga that is a spirit of
discipline it's not exercised spiritual
exercise that's exactly right
some of them say that the physical poses
or the physical act of worship
Wow for that religion and she said it's
the spirit of yoga and then she
qualified that in the
the spirit of the serpent dr. George
Alexander associate professor author of
yoga the truth behind the posture today
in the West about thirty five million
Americans are into yoga
just seeing yoga as a physical fitness
yoga is a Hindu word yoga is a Hindu
discipline to become one with the
universal consciousness which means
become one with God which God Brahma so
it's like the whole purpose for this
yoga is to become joined to this
universal consciousness and you think
about that a universal consciousness
well the consciousness has to be in the
mind well the eyes are the windows to
the soul
that's what that all-seeing eye is if
there's a universal consciousness who is
the eye what what is that a symbol of no
no I was going to make a comment back on
what Kenny said I'm just thinking about
like the the context of baptism you know
it's really sad
you know yoga for kids and Christians
doing yoga have you ever heard of a
Buddhist temple baptizing their kids and
staying Buddhists you know taking from
other religions and incorporating it
into theirs yeah why are we doing it in
Christianity you know when you think of
it in the reverse aspect of it it seems
silly you know what I mean it's like
you're doing these motions to connect
you to this God right just like you're
getting baptized to get connected to God
it's not that you're getting connected
to anything else I mean it's like
literally that action and you think
about like you know really what what
what power really does being dunked
underneath some water and coming back up
doing well there's nothing magical about
that water it's it's really just the act
of it that it's this self professing I
am giving my heart to God whereas to the
yoga person it's like I'm giving myself
to this God Brahma it's just interesting
you know it's interesting too because
with baptism it's also an act of faith I
am recognizing that I died with Christ
and
not I but he now lives within me in yoga
when you do these unbelievable poses
some of them are excruciatingly ly hard
you are saying I'm recognizing that your
presence is inside of me even if
somebody says no I'm thinking about
Jesus when I'm doing it you think well
in the Old Testament God didn't say go
worship like the heathen but you can do
it in my name he said don't worship the
way the heathen worship worship the way
I'm telling you to we're here in the
West doing yoga for exercise then we
have this man saying well it's more than
exercise it's actually this that and the
third right and we're like no no it's
exercise so I'm thinking like what it's
like people carrying on baptisms and
they're like no we're just dunking
people in water and the Christian walks
up and saying no like this is what it
means because this is where it
originated and why are we not you know
going to the origins of this why we just
do you understand the point we probably
do a lot of that kind of stuff and a lot
of things we do in the culture I mean
like some of the music and everything
when you when you dig down where did all
these drumbeats come from and things
like that like there's some dark stuff
to the to the roots of it yeah
what I'm getting at is it's more than
what we say or even not say I love the
way you answered my question in the in
the past episode ignorance does not stop
things from working the way they're
supposed to it would literally be like
I'm I'm going to wash in this river and
I'm gonna I'm gonna get baptized because
I need to wash why are you calling a
baptism yeah yeah I mean if you're gonna
wash why don't you just say I'm over
there washing it's like you don't need
to title it baptism to be like I'm
trying to make myself clean and it
really has nothing to do with this
spirituality of it but I'm still gonna
call it baptism well the the thing is
that let me this is really important
you can't take yoga and just rename it
that's right and that's important
because many go that's what we're doing
we're changing this pose name we're
changing this forms name we're just
going to call it something you have to
change what you're doing and my wife
said son
than she said you've got gymnastics
you've got ballet you've got all kinds
of stretching RIT runners stretch if you
want to stretch if you want to do but
you know exercise forgive me if you want
to exercise do something besides yoga
call it something besides yoga and you
know what the reply was well we don't
want to do that and you know what she
said she said if there was not a
spiritual power influencing through that
practice you would not be opposed to
changing the name right somebody says
hey that's the chair and you go no I
don't want to call it a share I'm going
to call it a stool okay fine but if you
say no I'm gonna call that a chair it
cannot be called a stool there's
something that's attaching you for you
to be that adamant about we're not going
to change what we call this yeah I was
thinking about how you can't just rename
it because we see that happening in the
Christian world with tarot cards and
stuff and severe guys they call them
angel boards oeg board is a nowadays
yeah that's terrifying yeah that is
listen to what this gentleman goes on
and says in Hinduism they have more than
330 million cards that means everything
is gone whatever you see whatever you
touch is God and the Sun God the moon
God and all all everything is God so man
and nature man and animal are one these
words spake Jesus and lifted up his eyes
to heaven and said father I pray that
they all may be one that does not mean
that every human being sees everything
identically listen to what what Jesus
said I pray that they all may be one as
you Father are in me and I in thee that
they also may be one in us he said he
wants for every one that follows him for
all of his children he wants us to have
the same relationship with
Father in heaven as he did John chapter
14 Jesus said the words I'm speaking
unto you it's not me speaking them it's
my father that's in me and you go
God was literally here in his son
speaking to us and that's pretty cool
because all that means everything that
Jesus did his father was in him with him
doing that forgiving the unforgivable
healing the incurable raising the dead
I mean lifting Mary Magdalene up out of
the dirt that was God the Father inside
of Jesus doing that then he said but I
couldn't do these things except the
father and he's yes it's also very
interesting that you know God like
Jesus's is knocking on the doors of our
hearts right like the whole Laodicean
message and we're to open our hearts to
him and let him in right it is an
unnatural thing for a spirit to come
into you that is not God amen literally
we are the temple of God we are only
designed to before God and and so when
we have Devils and things that come into
us that's not how God designed our
bodies really to do that and it's only
because Satan has fallen angels they're
there unlawfully so to say literally
coming in forcefully into us or even you
know we're inviting them or whatever but
it's not naturally purposeful for them
to be there you know I thought that came
to mind even if there was nothing
inherently wrong with yoga the end goal
is saying I am God right we have Jesus
God Himself refusing to call himself God
and he says no the father is in me so
following his example we need to be
looking for a Christ to come inside of
us not for the integral room for us to
be God so just off of that I would
refuse yoga this is where truth and
error runs so close together right you
know I mean because really it is about
having Christ in us that's the hope of
glory right and then the devil he wants
to be you know in that seat as well and
so you know calling yourself God and
and whatnot it's like you know we we are
inviting God into our hearts and and so
it sounds great but it's like the error
is that you you have that spark of
divinity in you which goes all the way
back to the tree of knowledge of good
and evil that's right I like what you
said Satan is looking for that place
that's see in our hearts it's like a
bait and switch because he makes you
think like you're in control he's like
no I'm really the one you just hope at
the door I'm coming you know what you
know what the difference is when Satan
comes in he does the work and gives you
the glory when Christ comes in he does
the work but he wants you to give God
the glory and that Satan is like I'm all
about man getting the glory because as
long as man thinks it's him that's doing
there he'll never be able to let Christ
come in because pride stops that this is
interesting this is from one of the
Hindu scriptures the bhagavad-gita and
hate to even use the word scripture it's
one of their religious texts but it says
that Yoga is the journey of self through
the self to the self I was just looking
at how this is self self self and I
noticed the through self to self and I
was like wait we're supposed to be
through Jesus to the Father you know die
old man die that man doesn't want that
because you know what there's no hope of
resurrection
Yoga literally means Union
etymologically that's connected to the
English word yoke Yoga means union with
God or what the Hindus call Brahma it's
not the same word but that's their view
of overall God or deity or the union of
the little ego self that's who you think
you are remember how Freud talked about
the it'd mm-hmm the ID it's your ID my
brain is a physical a physical organ of
the body it's not who you are it's only
a physical organ the mind you cannot put
a probe into or the mind is who you are
when you get rid of the ID or the it'd
you're getting rid of your identity
that's what this goal is the union of
the little
yourself with the divine self the
infinite spirit yoga this is from them a
Naga Sangha worldwide it's a yoga
Institute they say yoga is primarily a
spiritual discipline we say no it's not
it's just about stretching you know you
can do all kinds of stuff for stretch
but you don't have to do Hinduism to get
it dr. Victor Chaudhary a leading cancer
surgeon in India is also a well-known
lecturer and author of many books the
word yoga language means Union as simple
as that and the purpose of this union is
they think there is a power on the
living at the base of this bike which is
a kind of coiled serpent and the idea is
when this when this union takes place
this serpent is uncoiled and then it
travels into their buyers
that releases the third eye that is the
Shiva via the god Shiva
so the whole purpose for this practice
is to allow this energy which they
symbolize as a serpent to travel up the
body and when it gets to the spine it
goes through the spine and Hindu
teaching will say it's a two-headed
serpent some of them will say it's one
serpent but it always has symbolized as
having a light and a dark a yin and they
yong which is the same thing that the
caduceus staff you all familiar that you
see the staff and it's got the two
serpents that are in twining we see it
on the pharmaceutical pharmaceutical
companies medical symbols ambient
symbols and we're not going to go there
and the Baphomet has it yes so you have
these two serpents and then in the staff
of escalade pious which was the Greek
god of healing he had a single serpent
going up this this staff and they all
say people will say no no that's really
supposed to be Moses well Moses didn't
have two serpents with wings on them and
escalade pious didn't even believe in
Jesus Christ Jesus hadn't even come to
the earth yet he didn't believe in
Jehovah Yahweh he was a pagan
philosopher and healer I don't think we
can separate yoga the practice of yoga
from this ritual into it is a form of
exercise because every form of the yoga
movement derives from the serpent
and and there's a loot behind hitting so
in person practice yoga he's actually
indirectly bogging down did a god of
discipline it's really interesting I
spent a little bit of time in Taiwan and
went around to some of the grave sites
cuz they have these really amazing grave
sites in Taiwan it's amazing how many
serpents and Dragons are all over and
everybody's graves and you know that's
just like that's just like
characteristic of the devil right when
everybody's resurrected and he's like
these are mine right here yeah it's like
these this is really dealing with a
serpent in an ancient Gnosticism they
thought that the serpent was man Savior
because he freed us from this God that
wanted to control us Satan said do as
thou wilt shall be the whole of the law
you know there Aleister Crowley the
serpent became the symbol of divinity
where we know from the Bible the serpent
is really the one that stole man's
freedom it's like before sin nobody had
to die
you had no blemishes you had no problems
you had no sickness she had no death yet
nothing because we were living as God
intended as the sons and daughters of
God and Satan says had to do what you
want trust me it'll be more fun this way
and all of a sudden it's like there's
and and all of us probably know that to
one extent or another on me I know a
little bit of Scotty and Mikey's lives
I'm not gonna ask you ladies but I mean
you know I was like I wanna do what I
want to do I'm tired of this I'm tired
of that you know when my wife and I went
through the battle we had in our
marriage I was like I'm tired I don't
want this anymore
I want freedom and freedom I was
miserable during the day I could smile
and act like everything was great and at
nighttime when I was laying there in bed
you know alone it was empty
he was absent I could not stand the
silence it was deafening I'd keep the TV
on all the time just to have something
to keep me from hearing no voice of God
yeah because when you're one with Christ
and you spend time with him you don't
have that emptiness you're always you
hear his
voices words in your heart in your mind
I don't really understand when people
say God is a dictator or he's seeking to
control the fact that Satan got in the
garden to begin with just to bunks that
whole thing the fact that there was even
opportunity for Eve to sit there and
think mm and have that choice debunks
the whole thing of God being a
controller to do because choice was all
throughout the whole garden so really
that is I had never thought of that
Time magazine recently exposed a
controversy on yoga reporting that yoga
purists claim Hinduism is not like a
recipe ingredient that can be extracted
from yoga at the Hindu University of
America in Orlando Florida a professor
of yoga philosophy and meditation states
Yoga is Hinduism yet many espousing to
be Christians say they can adapt the
Hindu religion with Christian terms and
concepts that is scary and their teacher
these are their side this is from the
horse's mouth they're telling you I
remember I read one article actually
there were two one of the articles they
said that there were many of the you
yoga purist that were angry at what
Americans were doing with yoga they said
they're trying to separate the spiritual
from the physical activity and they said
you can't do that you're taking you're
taking something that's ours and you're
trying to make it yours they're angry
and then and then you know what was
amazing I read another article and they
actually said when I was in the martial
arts the Shaolin Temple they had a
photograph of all of these monks coming
out of the temple they were holding this
Golden Globe in their hand and you see
all these warriors with these swords and
spears and then there's all these months
coming out with this Golden Globe and I
was like what in the world what does
that mean and I remember I looked in the
back of the book where you could get the
English translation and it meant
literally Buddhism into all the world
that was their translation Jesus said go
into all the world and proclaim these
glad tidings that I reign this world is
not the devil's anymore it's more
I'm the king of kings and yet they said
on this Hindu website they said our goal
like the Buddhists is to eat these this
word evangelize the world with Hinduism
that's what the word evangelical means
it's not a Christian term evangelical
just means whatever your faith is you
are evangelizing the world
well the Hindu website said our goal is
to evangelize the entire world with
Hinduism and they said we have achieved
the greatest success in the Western
countries of America and Europe because
we have a church on every street corner
a yoga studio oh so you're learning
religious principles and philosophies
just like people take their you know
children to martial arts classes
yeah little Johnny is learning how to
punch and kick and stand in a stance but
he's learning Eastern thought patterns
and philosophy and religion can there be
a physical yoga without spiritually I
[Music]
love how they're getting different
people to say that this is the doctor I
know listen to what he says some
Christians believe that you can
Christianize anything including yoga and
all you do is cut out the Hindu part of
it this is really a big thing when you
think of things like you know Halloween
and a lot of stuff like that you know
Christianizing it the trunk-or-treat
know that kind of thing yeah I know I
thought it was awesome when I saw a
video that this guy went to a pagan
gathering and was literally asking all
the pagans you know what's the deal with
these Christians stealing your you know
your symbols and stuff and dude the
pagans were like yeah they stole
Christmas and they incorporated this and
then that I mean they're literally
telling you all the things that they've
done as Christians have robbed that from
them but they're like it's just the
roots are in paganism and it was
interesting to hear that from a pagans
perspective you know not just a
Christians perspective that's something
that that I have to encourage myself
with
need to be people of the book if I'm
doing something doesn't matter what
church I go to what denomination I'm
part of if I'm doing something I need to
go to God's Word and say can I find it
in here yeah if I can't I need to get
rid of it this is a an interesting video
it's called Christ's toga Christian yoga
yeah I'm not going to condemn the ladies
I think they probably really think
they're doing what's right but they
haven't they haven't seen the truth they
don't know what they're involved in the
Bible tells us in first Corinthians know
ye not that your bodies are members of
Christ shall I then take the members of
Christ and make them members of a harlot
god forbid what know ye not that he
which is joined to a harlot is one body
hmm and I'm gonna pause there just for a
moment one of the things that used to
terrify men and women 20 30 40 years ago
especially if they were in the military
is you know I'm not married or maybe I'm
married and my wife's not gonna find out
about it but if I go out on the street
and I sleep with somebody I could come
home with something I can't get rid of
that do you know the same thing happens
to the Internet it's called a virus if
you're joined to a harlot male or female
you become one flesh whatever they have
now has equal access to you and that
goes with spiritually when I was in the
martial arts I became one not physically
but through the martial arts training
and the ceremony when you made black
belt in any of the styles that I was in
you became one with the the master or
Grandmaster well whatever spirits were
influencing him now had legal rights to
come into your life and begin
influencing you do anything our in you
you think some of those spiritual or
some of those like ritualistic things
you were doing was that was telling the
demons he's giving us access he's doing
all those things yeah yes which makes me
think of what that guy was saying these
specific poses are to the moon
that's right so the demons are watching
saying well they're invoking us Joanne
you can change the name while you want
and God is he is so merciful because he
doesn't the devil if he want to do it be
like BAM I mean they did it one time and
also in your possession and gods like ah
look you're an angel fallen corrupt but
they're only human you can't go in and
take over them once in you know so it's
like God and His mercy it's like he
keeps holding that door closed and if we
keep opening that door time and time and
time again sooner or later they come in
and they take they take over the house
yeah if God were to remove his protect
protection we'd be like Jobe that's
exactly right
Lloyd man anyway he says don't you
realize that he that is joined to a
harlot is one body but listen to what he
goes on and says for to say if he shall
be one flesh
but he or she that is joined to the Lord
is one spirit
if God was in Christ reconciling the
world unto himself and we become married
to Christ
whatever Christ has we have dear the
Bible says that in the through first
John he says as he is so are we in this
world we are joint heirs through him
that loves us that's powerful I mean
it's like you know wow but that's the
union that God wants with his people and
that's the only way we'll ever have
victory over sin is by becoming one with
Christ the only way that he did not have
one sin in his life was because he had
complete union with his father that's
what he came to give us on Calvary amen
and on a side note because you mentioned
this earlier atonement the atonement of
Christ the word atonement literally
means at one ment right what he did on
Calvary which is what he prayed in John
17 was he made God and man 1 again he
opened that way so that we through faith
can be joined to him Deepak Chopra how
many people are familiar with him and
he's well known he's a he's a
Hindu Indian doctor listen to what he
says he says thus the divine pervades
the entire universe as well as human
beings and every person has divinity
within himself or Horsell herself Chopra
writes that sounds like the force and
Star Wars
which is where George Lucas got it from
right he was blending Buddhism Hinduism
all of those together in a sci-fi fairy
tale because it was acceptable in our
generation Chopra goes on and says we
remain unfilled full unless we nurture
the seeds of divinity within us in
reality we are divinity in disguise and
the gods and goddesses in embryo that
are contained within us are seeking to
be fully materialized go all the way
back to the Garden of Eden we're still
listening to the lies that we're told at
that tree and it's like this is how it's
just materialized in our modern
generation and was terrible they're even
getting it from the serpent yes I mean
they're yeah about that yeah and it's
interesting too because it says these
things that are within us he tells us
it's already there you just have to
develop it what other Hindu writers say
well you want to know how to develop it
philosophy yoga Eastern mysticism
meditation mindfulness if you do these
practices it'll awaken that sleeping
serpent that's down there at the base
and it'll get it up here to climb the
tree again he says they're waiting to be
fully materialized well I don't want
demonic powers manifesting or
materializing in my life how many has
ever heard this term namaste yeah what
they say at the end of beginning and
ending and it's interesting because when
you go to most people and you ask them
what is that oh it's just a greeting it
means blessings and blah blah blah but
when you go to the Hindu website in
Sanskrit this is what the actual
definition is the divine within me
bowels to the divine or God and goddess
within you
so it is a religious activity Yoga is
not just merely stretching okay so have
no other gods before me do not bow down
to them but you're saying I'm bowing to
you you're a god yes let's hope they
don't say that in holy yoga that would
be interesting to look up picked up this
cool little term it's in the Mustang
it sounds neat you know Namastey no man
no nasty now remember what the avatar
movie looked like these are actual
artwork of actual Hindu avatars a6a
Graham isn't it interesting that they're
blue well this is very interesting
because we just did a video on on what's
a little verlande genie oh yeah yeah
Aladdin and Aladdin's blue and og thank
you the genies blue and he comes from
from a mixture of all these different
gods
you have to serpent around it's nice
yeah any of you who was it the blade the
gene Aladdin yeah Gina
Will Smith go online and just find out
some of the things he believes in his
religious it's scary because he believes
the same thing pantheism which is
interesting cuz then technically it's
fine for him to play something like that
because those are his beliefs so what is
the quest Christian doing sitting down
and taking in all this stuff and you
know I remember one interview that was
done with Will Smith and he said people
ask me about my religious faith he said
I believe in a God and I ingratiate
myself to that God in order to receive
benefits in my life what does ingratiate
mean I cooperate I do everything I can
to please to be in good graces with this
this power that you think okay so wait a
minute now if a lot of those actors open
themselves up to the same spiritual
powers to empower them in acting when I
sit down in front of a movie am i
watching a person or could I possibly be
watching a demon manifesting itself
through human flesh and like you brought
out candy it
funny because he has a cobra wrapped
around his neck and that's what Satan
does to everybody I won't really hurt
you I'm your friend
he's whispering in your ear and he's
there and he's loose and makes you feel
comfortable
and then when he gets done using you the
noose just grows tight and he strangles
you one of the things that we have found
in martial arts and Tai Chi and yoga is
that when someone is into the practice
for a little while they begin to to
either not here or not be able to
distinguish the voice of God anymore
it's like the the snake or the Python
cuts off the flow of air to the heart
it's like you can have head knowledge
but it won't reach your heart and that's
terrifying because I've been there
before it's like I knew what the Bible
said but it was like my heart was like
just yeah it was just like it was in a
steel container and nothing I could do
would would open it and it wasn't until
I told God I'm nothing I'm will I told
God I'm willing to dig ditches I'm
willing to clean bathrooms and gas
stations on my hands and knees as long
as you'll let me hear your voice man and
when you humble yourself God picks you
up it is interesting that here in this
ancient picture this pagan deity is
holding the same symbol of a there's a
lot of similarities in the and some of
the Catholicism and stuff like this hat
thing and the the fish-like the soul has
to do with Dagon yes and I've even seen
the hexagram on the Pope's hat yes and
it's interesting to the colors of the
children that she's holding the to her a
mother holds a baby to its chest for
what to nourish them to feed them
Hinduism says we're gonna raise your
children well there's one trying to get
away this way red and yellow black and
white yeah all her precious in His sight
and this was done hundreds and hundreds
I wanted to evangelize it all to the
world the Bible says know ye not that to
whom we yield ourselves as servants to
obey his servants we are to whom we obey
whether of sin
unto death or of obedience unto
righteousness and life when we go and we
participate in things that God has told
us please don't do this you're gonna
open the door we're yielding we're
opening that door and you know what what
the devil says I got every right to be
here they invited me it's only through
God's showing us light and then we can
go to God and say God I messed up
forgive me for disobeying you not
trusting you mmm
I repent set me free and Christ will
come in and nothing can stand in his way
same old cylinder Dragon has gone to
deceive the whole world and the spirit
of the separate issue
tries to deceive the whole body preach
sister she knows what's up that's kind
of interesting in light of the first guy
that we saw in the beginning of yours I
think in the beginning of this one there
there Yoga is just taking the world by
storm you know I mean I was going out to
deceive the whole world text that's
right what else can you say and then she
says to possess the body we our bodies
are God's temple Satan said I'm gonna
set my throne and you're in God's temple
I'm gonna be like the Most High in
second Thessalonians it says he's gonna
set himself up in the temple of God
proclaiming himself to be God there may
be something that happens over in the
Middle East I have you know who knows
that doesn't bother me but what's
important is is knowing am i allowing
Satan to have the throne in my life
whoever I yield to that's who I obey
Jesus said why do you call me King King
but yet don't do the things that I say
you say I'm your Lord but yet you live
as if you didn't have one
this author Maya describes Kundalini
before we read her quote though I want
to read to you something that comes from
another one of the Hindu scriptures it
says the divine power Kundalini shines
like the stem of a young Lotus like a
snake coiled round upon herself she
holds her tail in her mouth and lies
resting half asleep at the base of the
body a serpent with its tail in its
mouth what's that called my key
I never was girl Bora
we saw it around the hexagram a second
ago the oral Boris that symbol has been
around for thousands of years in the
occult what that symbol actually means
is is that I don't need to go outside of
myself to get life I can find life in
myself I can eat myself and keep
regenerating well then Maya goes on and
says Kundalini or Shakti coiled and
dormant feminine energy is the vast
potential of psychic energy contained
within us all do you know that many of
the yoga teachers are now saying that
this energy is what the Christians call
the holy spirit they say it's the same
thing
the Chinese say it's Chi the Japanese
say it's ki the Hindus call it prana
Polynesians call it mana and they say
Christians call it the Holy Spirit but
it's all the same thing we just have
different names for it which is a lie
the easiest way for me to to make sure
to draw a line is from Thomas that Jesus
gave us in John 6:63 he said the words I
speak unto you they are spirit and they
are life because it's not me saying them
it's my father that's in me so whenever
I hear something and it contradicts the
Word of God I know it's not of God God's
Spirit quickens us it convicts us of sin
it leads us in righteousness it
glorifies our Savior Jesus Christ as the
only begotten Son of God
the only son of God this spirit and any
other spirit like it will not do that
and it also teaches like us that our
best efforts are like filthy rags I
merely like there's nothing that we can
do the Holy Spirit is is is convicting
us that we are literally like nothing
and and it's interesting that this kind
of a spirit that comes into them is like
no you you you can be this like great
enlightened person and you're this it's
totally different within every human
lies a divine cosmic energy called
Kundalini and this is from one of the
Hindu gurus almost every tradition
speaks of this power in one form or
and describes Kundalini in its own way
and Japanese it is called ki in Chinese
it is called Chi
what is that Kundalini it is the power
of the self the power of consciousness
Kundalini is Shakti supreme energy whom
the sages of India worship as the mother
of the universe Yin in y'all light and
darkness at the same time it is only
when Kundalini is awakened that we
become aware of our true nature of our
greatness of the fact look at that of
our greatness hmm of the fact that not
only do we belong to God but that we are
God when one acquires the strength of
Kundalini one expands infinitely then
one of simulates the whole universe one
is able to see the whole universe within
oneself one no longer remains a bound
limited creature one achieves total
union with God I don't I don't believe
in Carl Jung I mean he was obviously was
pagan he was not a good man not a
Christian but it was interesting because
he had written an entire book that was
devoted to the examination through
psychology of Kundalini he was heavily
into Eastern mysticism because he was
trying to identify the it'd who we are
and what was happening inside of our
minds and he told people in that book he
warned them don't get involved in this
unless you were under the really really
strong protection and guidance of a
master he said because you could go
insane he said you can lose your mind
yeah I've seen people who are filled
with the Kundalini spear and they're
twitching and they have no control that
that's why I thought a stranger that
said that you some about self control or
something you totally are not in control
the lie is that you are this greatness
but really you're just a puppet yeah
that's a good point no that's a good
point this is gonna be our last clip
this shows where this type of thinking
leads
house prior show maybe 10,000 people
worshipping celebrating a gentleman
having his own personal experience with
God this is clearly faith in the God in
you your inspiration your power God has
so many things to so many people the
warm light of the Sun a sound of sweet
music and inner voice that drives us
forward a friend if you ask me who God
is
I would say there's a bit of the divine
in all of us this garden you it's God in
me the God in me is who I really am at
my core the God in me is the best
version of me the God in me is who I
strive to be
who I was meant to be la mejor parte de
los habitant Iselle Planeta declaran
crescentus esto debería prabhakar on
Gron trail our Ediciones no debemos day
Harvey or our por el ecolab or our con
quien quien SE distinto confio en bois
de creo en Dios creo que su Christo creo
en Dios Allah muchos piensan distinto C
intended Tinto Bakken adios UN Quentin
agave River salmon era en esta multitude
en Esteban eco say ready Sione's arena
so Lacerta sake tenemos palatov todos
somos it was videos
[Music]
creo en el amor creo en el amor creo en
el amor creo en el amor confirm boss
para definitely petición de tomates
Chaldea lo vas is zero interest inherits
the diverse religions conjure a fruit of
the past
we hope this configuration
Wow there's a lot to to even just
analyze in the way that they're bringing
this together I mean what I heard
just from the from the the catholic pope
here he basically said you know there's
a lot of people that they believe in god
this way or a lot of people that
interpret god this way and then notice
how they blend it in there everybody's
like i fall in love i follow up i follow
up so the common ground is love doesn't
matter who which god you serve that it's
literally blending all these and really
it's all we're all one and we're all
getting to the same end goal and current
event the the pope is trying to get
everybody to be re-educated next year he
wants all the world leaders to sign this
thing the pope's really been a prominent
figure in a lot of united nations
unifying things and obama even said all
world leaders heed to the post message
you know the word catholicism means
universal right and the word yoga meant
union union with the universal energy
it's all the same man that this is
Satan's agenda is to is to bring about a
new world religion a worldwide religion
that looks like peace and safety but
sudden destruction will come upon them
this is gonna be hard to stand on truth
when you look like the one that's
opposed to this unity love but you're
saying you're right and we're all wrong
do you know something something that
really and I want to I want to really
encourage our viewers open your bibles
like you never have before because when
I watched that video for Morgan Freeman
it was almost hypnotizing yeah I mean
his voice and the is manner he he
believes this he was not just acting
that you can do research on it he
believes what he was doing this
documentary was was done a few years ago
and it was almost three hours long and
the whole documentary he visited every
religion in the world just about and
this was the end of the documentary it's
all one it's all one God we call him
different things but they they they keep
tying it back to like Scotty sit it's
about love
we all have one thing in common love and
you know what caught my attention a
quote that I have from more EIU a Shiva
he was the founder of the Aikido system
you know martial arts
he said there's many paths that leave to
the top of Mount Fuji but there's only
one summit guess what the summit was
love and I was like this guy was so
piggy he said he worshipped millions of
gods but yet he said he had the same
goal is what these people are saying and
you know what hit me what is love in the
Bible first John this is a love of God
that we keep his Commandments and His
commandments are not Grievous he that
saith he knoweth God and keepeth not his
Commandments it's a liar he's deceived
so it's not doesn't make me any better
than somebody else and it doesn't mean
just externally keeping a law it means
internally because if I say hey you
shouldn't be stealing and I'm lusting in
my heart that's right I'm just as guilty
and the only way that can be changed is
if we allow Christ and our Father to
come in and cleanse the temple of our
heart I also want to make sure that
people know that just because it feels
like love doesn't mean it's of God I've
heard people say no no Satan can't do
anything love all his stuff is
destruction and I know the difference
but people who smoked DMT have
life-changing experiences they say I
felt the most loved I've ever felt I
felt one with God and they come out
completely changed ayahuasca ecstasy all
these things you know ask all the
hippies and stuff they were feeling
loved you gotta ask yourself is that
truly of God Satan can transform himself
as an angel of light I know don't get
the whole boogeyman picture he can he
can make it look very appealing and very
loving but that's the major deception
what fellowship hath light with darkness
it has none amen
2nd Corinthians chapter 6 it tells us
that it says there is no union
komm union between light and darkness so
you know it doesn't mean that you can't
love people and care about them but we
have no business walking in their ways
yes in participating in their pagan
practices even if they don't know any
better
all right thank you for your expertise
Mikey a good job I'm in thank you my
really showing us the the roots of this
thing we hope that you guys had you know
a blessing watching this we hope you
guys learn something and really you know
if you're if you're questioning just the
practice of yoga or even doing the moves
we hope that you'll you'll really look
into this a little bit more I mean do a
little bit of research do a little bit
of praying about it you know be if you
are involved in yoga I mean simply just
sit there and and spend some time in
prayer with God and say God is this
something that you want me to be
involved in if it's not then then you
know please speak to my heart tell me
show me something give me some evidence
on why you won't and I believe strongly
that God will not like ignore you he
will show you and direct you that's what
he tells us when we ask him he tells us
to go right or to go left so prayerfully
think about that and we want to hear
about your comments of course if you're
new to this channel welcome thank you
for watching click that little subscribe
button and hit the bell for the
notifications and check out some of our
other videos we've got lots of other
cool topics and if you want to be a
supporter of us please check out our
patreon page we've got a lot of cool
perks for those people that really want
to help see us put more content out just
like this we thank you guys for watching
and we'll see you next week
Friday's at noon
[Music]